foreign
I got this direct message I'll just say
it's from Jack Jack if you're listening
you know who you are
um I'm super glad you reached out here's
what Jack wrote
I love your show John
I'm a redneck tough Midwest guy and I
enjoy the heck out of it dude I already
like you jack we're already we're
already good friends
one thing I gotta ask
why in every episode you tell someone to
pick up a rock and drop it I tried it
and the whole time I think about how
stupid it feels instead of getting rid
of the grief am I doing it wrong
dude great question Jack thanks for
sending that on the internet
um for sliding into my DMs I think this
is how the kit nope that's not nope
that's not what they said okay
um thank you for sending me an
electronic message from the Midwest Jack
um okay a couple things
carrying around throwing a rock picking
up and throwing it is not going to heal
your grief okay
when I tell somebody to go to the store
and buy a brick buy a cinder block and
write on it what's this thing you're
carrying around
whether that's hatred for somebody rage
for somebody an inability to forgive
yourself
I want you to carry it
past the point where it's comfortable
obviously don't get injured don't do
anything it's gonna
cause you harm
but I want your body to feel how heavy
this is
I want you to carry it around to the
part that your shoulders are heavy your
hands are heavy it's it's scraping on
your hand it's just heavy
and then I want you to do walk all the
way you can to the back corner of your
backyard for some of you living in
condos or apartments that's not very far
walk you may go out to a park for some
of y'all in a big place it might be a
long walk
but the whole thing is a miniature
pilgrimage but from
where I am right now to I am going down
and I'm going to set this thing down and
when you set it down
and you stand up
that lightness that freedom feeling
I want your body to get a tiny little
glimpse of what it's going to feel like
when you're not carrying around somebody
else's anger when you're not carrying
around somebody else's bad decisions
that they made that you still hate that
drunk driver that took your dad 14 years
ago or seven years ago
that anger in that rage is not helping
your dad come back it's not further
punishing the drunk driver it's just
making your life
more miserable
and so Jack dude is just a metaphor for
how heavy these things are that we carry
we don't realize
that the poison that we carry has a
physiological consequence every time we
spin up and think up about that drunk
driver our body starts the threat
response system again and let's dump
cortisol and adrenaline into the
bloodstream and get this sucker fired up
again because we gotta fight or we gotta
run from something and there's no way to
fight anymore there's nobody to run from
you become Your Own Worst Enemy
and so Jack uh it's just simply a
metaphor walking out your backyard and
just picking up a rock and being like
I looked at a bad website and then
throwing it on the ground that's not the
point the point is to say I'm carrying
this thing around and I want to stop and
it also is not going to assist with your
grief at all in fact it will amplify
your grief
it will free you up to finally feel
I'm trying to think sometimes whenever I
go rocking I've got my goruck bag and
I've got it filled with some weights and
I would go walk it's so heavy and all I
can feel are the straps in my back all I
can feel is my shoulders tense and me
hunched oh it's just so heavy
I don't feel how much my feet hurt and
how much my knees hurt
until I take it off I drop that thing
and then I realized oh that's how tired
I am oh that's my knees or girl like I
need to stretch whatever the thing is
then I can finally feel my entire body
but until I take that backpack off I'm
just feeling where those straps are
digging in
and so we often carry around anger or
rage and we think it's just them it's
just them it's just that it's us we're
the ones paying the price for that
hatred that rage that frustration that
lack of forgiveness it's us
and so really it's just an exercise it's
a metaphor
um the feedback I've received has just
been second to none
folks who said okay I'm gonna do this
and I'm gonna set it down and when it
pops back in your mind the next day you
can be like nope I put that down in the
backyard I've got a place where I put it
down it's like going to a funeral I've
got a point when I said goodbye to my
grandmother I got a point when I said
goodbye to my kids
we got a funeral and we said goodbye
it's it's that process so
um thanks for your question man I love
you dude and I hope you come visit us
here in Nashville sometime I'd love to
um I was gonna say buy you a cup of
coffee but it's free here in the lobby
if y'all ever want to come visit but
um thank you so so much for that
question Jack everybody
you got something in your past It's
haunting you that you've done that was
done to you try it
go buy a cinder block pay the money go
through the process buy it put a piece
of duct tape on it or a piece of masking
tape on it write down what happened
just carry it around with you
15 minutes 20 minutes some of you may
only be able to carry it for two minutes
right
and then take it somewhere where it's
going to sit down forever maybe you go
on a hike with it out in a in a park and
you carry it out into the woods and you
set it down and say this is where this
this is where this gets left forever
and then every time you think of it in
the future you realize it's already over
there give that a shot let me know how
it goes